these next few words from robert
kiwasaki so i'm standing in front of
like 500 muslims are huge now when we
come back after we listen to them i'm
going to let you know why they're huge
and what we can benefit from them and
also
i got a free gift for you at the end i'm
in istanbul speaking to muslims
so i realized what i was taught
about radicalized islam was inaccurate i
think that's the problem we don't
understand each other lack of education
correct so i'm standing in front of like
500 muslims and i have no idea what
muslims are and they're good people now
for those that don't know who robert
kiwasaki is many view him as a legendary
figure who has changed the way how
people look at money
an entrepreneur investor author and
motivational speaker by profession he is
the author of the book rich dad poor dad
so in a nutshell robert kiwasaki he's
famous he's rubbed elbows with some of
the most influential famous people
well-known people in america and they
say he's brilliant when it comes to
money making money he's the king of the
dunya
and at the same time he's humble enough
to admit when he's wrong so let's get
into his first statement what he was
taught about radicalized islam was
inaccurate what he probably meant to say
was what he was taught about islam was
wrong as there's no radical islam islam
is islam peace and purpose in life
gained by submission to the creator's
will not your desires to the one and
only god almighty allah this is islam
and then he said i had no idea what
muslims are but they're good people
alhamdulillah three points and takeaways
i want to leave robert kiyosaki with and
you three points i want to leave robert
kiwasaki with and you the audience
number one be humble and know your
limits you see just to strike an example
i'm a black belt professor of gracie
brazilian jiu jitsu alhamdulillah i
don't know capoeira or tai chi so it's
not my business to be talking too much
about capoeira or tai chi you see this
man's brilliant on what he focused in on
and mastered and that's making money but
knows nothing about islam except
probably the wrong information that he's
gotten from the fake news and
misinformation media machine probably
the corrupt divide and conquer
politicians ignorant religious leaders
and the islamophobia business machine
that manufactures fear and hate number
two look how powerful the human
connection is when he connected with all
the muslims and the proper education is
you see robert kirasaki just got a taste
of but imagine if he continues with his
skills learning and growing about islam
and others who are in the same ignorant
state that he was
and ignorant just means just not knowing
they can learn a lot from these simple
but brilliant words of robert kiwasaki
and before we go on to the third and
final point just imagine how many people
are out there they're brilliant and
whatever they focus in on just like he's
brilliant in this area of expertise but
they know nothing about islam we had
recently jordan peterson who also was
humble enough to say he just doesn't
know but he in the past made some
blunders huge blunders when he started
to open up and talk about islam then
when he was educated by people who are
experts in the field he was like i
really don't know he was humble enough
we have another instance now robert
kiwisaki we've got to make this trend
keep going that people are not you know
how many times that you corner someone
where now they're brilliant in one
aspect and now you start to go ahead and
get into another subject and then they
just start blabbering on they just start
going on talking and they're talking
rubbish they're talking maybe what
they've heard from some of the media
outlets and from these other avenues
that are representing islam in the wrong
way so this is a very key very key
important point just because someone is
an expert in one area it's common sense
just i gave you an example of myself i
don't talk about capoeira or tai chi i
don't start talking about economics and
other areas and get out of my league get
out of my lane you got to stay in your
lane so he admits islam was an accurate
i think that's the problem we don't
understand each other and how many are
you out there you probably been fed the
wrong information you got to be humble
enough and say i don't know
and if you want to learn if you're
sincere we're here to help you grow now
third and final point let me give you a
simple quick overview of islam and a
gift at the end for your patience and
eagerness to learn and grow and note
each one of these can be elaborated on
for hours lectures can be given but i'm
just giving you a taste let's start off
with islam like i said earlier islam is
to gain peace and purpose in his life by
submitting your will not to yourself not
to your desires not to your mind not to
your logic not to your human being or
anything in creation but to the will of
the creator of the hems and earth god
almighty allah and a muslim is one who
does that action of submitting his or
her will to the creator that has an
earth and just a beautiful point
everything in creation
submits itself to the creator of
heaven's earth the sun the moon the
stars the animals everything in creation
it has no choice but to surrender its
will but the human being has a choice is
he or her gonna submit his or her will
to your desires or to the one who
created the human being god almighty
allah now islam is built on
six articles of faith and five pillars
now the six articles of faith compared
to when you're erecting a house first
you have to do the excavation and then
you build the foundation this is
underground this is in your heart if you
can believe this then you're on your way
to becoming a muslim
you're on your way to accepting islam
real quickly and simply the six articles
are the belief these are the believe
this is what you believe they start with
the belief in one and only one god the
creator of the heavens and the earth not
a trinity not three in one but one
unique creator of the heavens and the
earth in every we say allah he doesn't
become born he doesn't die he doesn't
drink eat food go to the bathroom he's
not ignorant of anything he knows all
things
he's not a human being he's not an angel
he doesn't have associates or partners
this he's
absolutely one it's the pure belief in
pure monotheism number two
in the angels
and the revelation that came through
these angels to the messengers the
belief in the messengers the books the
authentic strip scriptures that revealed
we have the for example was given to
moses in his original the torah what was
given to jesus
in its original the injil what was given
to
prophet muhammad which we have today is
a living miracle the quran the verbatim
word of god almighty the quran the
belief in these books in their original
pristine form and then you have the
belief in the day of judgment paradise
to hell fire and
the predestiny so there you have it
quick and simple the six articles of
faith the belief in one and only one god
the angels the messengers the divine
books that were revealed the day of
judgment paradise hellfire and
pre-destiny so when you believe in this
this is an in the heart this is what you
believe you're firmly
convinced of this
and now you have to testify you have to
put it in action the house is built on
the foundation that's the articles of
faith and now you come up to the pillars
so the house is constructed on the
foundation and now what holds it up are
these pillars and we have the five
pillar look how beautiful this is how it
all sinks in the five pillars of islam
so if you believe what we just talked
about these articles now you profess it
now it has to come out not just stays in
your heart you have to profess it
through your tongue and through your
limbs through actions because of as i
often say talk is cheap so number one is
pillar is that you testify that there's
nothing worthy of worship except the
creator that has an earth god almighty
allah and that muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him just like the
preceding messengers he was a messenger
but the final just to name a few we had
noah abraham moses jesus peace be upon
him these were some of the greatest
messengers and muhammad just being the
final messenger sent to mankind so you
testify
this testimony of faith and now you
start establishing the second pillar
which is prayer minimum five times a day
you start to pay the poor due tax as the
third pillar you start to fast during
the month of ramadan this is another
pillar and if you're physically
financially able you make the pilgrimage
to not disneyland but to hajj mecca
these are the five pillars of faith and
this is islam this is what it is and
books are written on all these things
and the final thing i want to say is
that i'm very elated and happy to hear
someone like robert kiwisaki so i'm
standing in front of like 500 muslims
and i have no idea what muslims are and
they're good people and hopefully others
will come out and be humble enough to
say they just don't know they've been
wrong
and many people 99 of the people
probably out there who've gotten
information from the mainstream media
and they have this you know fear and
apprehension they are people who've been
misinformed they're wrong
and if they admit that to themselves
they start to tune into the dean show
they start to seek help from the creator
that heavens and earth god almighty the
one and only for guidance
hopefully
they can be on a new road of learning
and growing and expanding their heart
and mind and i i want to fulfill my
promise i promise to get you a gift at
the end for your eagerness to learn and
grow and for your patience which is a
free copy of the quran
so you're humble enough to sit through
all this
and open enough so i'm going to go ahead
and have you visit the deanshow.com
visit the website and go ahead and we'll
get you a free copy of the quran thank
you very much and i invite robert
kiwisaki i'd love to have you on the
program so we can talk more about your
experiences there in istanbul with the
muslims
and hopefully others it can be a benefit
where others can hear more about this
journey so they can also expand their
mind because we need more education in
these topics proper education more of
this human connection
so we can get rid of this manufactured
fear and hate
and we can go ahead and learn to live in
peace with one another thank you for
tuning in subscribe if you haven't
already leave your comments in the
comments below and we look forward to
seeing you here support us on our
patreon page we look forward to seeing
you again here on the dean show until
next time peace be with you assalamu
alaikum